e
uh it is now 10:00 and um so I'm going
to go ahead and uh convene um the this
work session division work session of
division 3 uh this is uh the 14th of
February
2025 we've got two bills uh on our
agenda today hp71
HP
519 both with um a fiscal note and and
then we have an amendment floating
around that I I hope to talk about um to
to to you know see if we can get aligned
on the right way to settle those down so
is there
um Mr Ripple just technically I think it
would be more efficient if we talked
about HB 59 first okay um but uh do am I
required to go in the order that's
presented you're not okay
okay so um based on conversations and
some testimony from uh and and do we
have the
amendment so I have the amendment to 519
that was handed out at the public
hearing last week I also have your
proposed amendment to House Bill 71 okay
so let's go ahead and uh when you get a
chance hand out the amendment to 71 is
it in our packet
already okay all right
so again based on testimony and
conversations um uh there there uh it it
it it it became
clear that um there's a a a preference
um out of out of politeness and respect
uh and to further assure uh the primary
beneficiary of that
Waypoint U that we were going to keep a
commitment to consider them in the
budget process and um and although they
were told on record um that they should
not worry about 519 there's still some
concern by in some quarters that that if
we do anything odd to 519 it's going to
cause con nation and shock waves so
rather than do that um I think that the
amendment the non gerain amendment that
we
debated probably is better to go on to
hp71 and that we'll leave 519
alone and and uh we can't execute today
though right 519 out of division
three you could vote to make a
recommendation on 519 I think you
couldn't on House Bill 71 if you wanted
to offer this amendment right okay so so
so we may get to that uh here in a
moment but um so I my proposal is to
leave
519 as
introduced um and retain
519 as a
committee and to intend to take the
subject matter of 5199 and put it into
hb2 and in the budget process that's
going to take place over the next six
weeks determine uh the level that uh we
think we can fund it at so so without
committing to money I want to commit us
to a process of retaining 519 putting
the material in
hb2 uh and then determining at a later
date the the level of funding that's my
that's my proposal uh that's not a
motion but it's open for
discussion yes thank you very much um I
want to thank you for that um adjustment
in the plan I think that um there was
con concern about the Waypoint bill and
I appreciate um us being able to move
forward and keeping it clean um I'm
happy with that idea and um I don't wh I
see someone in the public wants to
comment so I will refrain from going on
too much further but um I just want to
say I appreciate that effort okay so we
still don't have a motion on the floor
but and I don't think we need one if do
you have um as a member of the public
would you like to speak about what we're
proposing to do on HB 519 if so this is
the time to go to the table and do that
and you need to introduce yourself
because the representative here needs
hi um members of the committee um my
name's Mary Rose De and um I have uh an
awareness of this bill and feel that the
monies could be used better spent to
teach the youth skills real skills that
they can use in the workplace rather
than um wasted on Mental Health Services
they could be taught how to use a
construction equipment or be taught a
skill a real skill rather than be told
that they're mental ill and disabled
they could be saying well you're able to
do these things you can get a forklift
and go out and plow snow or whatever and
we'll teach you how to do it rather than
just telling them that they're
nuts and helping these mental
health I consider them
frauders um get more money um it's to me
it's a waste of money that could be
better spent teaching real skills that
these people need to make it in the
world to have faith in themselves have
faith in their um
abilities have faith in their uh
feelings of success instead of being
told that they're crazy and will be
disabled for the rest of their lives so
I am opposed to this um Waypoint funding
bill um and uh would
appreciate maybe the Department of
Employment Security or some other skill
building
organizations could bid on um teaching
these people to have faith in
theirselves and their
abilities instead of telling them
they're disabled losers that the only
their only way out is to take drugs or
something they could feel confident that
they're going to have skills and go on
the work place or construction site and
um know how to wire an electrical
circuit or uh know how to build a
circuit board or something like that I I
I think we get the gist of your
testimony U are are you willing to take
questions yes I am okay this this this
these are questions this is not an
intent to debate you because we I would
not be very good at that but I'm just
seeing what's out there on the street
now how um the mental health system has
let these people down by telling them
they're disabled right and they're
losers and instead of just saying well
you're great person right here what
we're going to show you uh how to use a
sow okay yes uh so the subject matter of
this uh of 519 is really specifically
aimed at uh trying to provide uh
financial resources from the state for
the first time to Waypoint and their
shelter operation they have a shelter
operation of 14 and and they uh they do
have a program to do wraparound Services
similar not exactly but similar to what
you're saying they're trying to give
them some life skills are you are you
familiar with the Waypoint specifically
and their shelter and the wraparound
services that they provide um well I've
seen people on the street with similar
services that they get but yes ma'am I'm
I'm asking you specifically though if if
your comments are in general about Point
specific any kind of Mental Health
Organization as such is basically
telling the people that they're disabled
l or nut jobs that can't get work and
will be losers for the rest of their
life and so they may as well take drugs
and hang around the streets sure and
even if they go to these things so I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to uh
conclude your testimony because I I
think we've heard you and understand you
your comment are in general related to
the entire way in which our system of
care is operating and not specifically
towards this the subject of this bill if
it's Mental Health Care Facility yeah
then it it's it's a waste time and money
right and um they're overcharging
they're overburdening the budgets of
states and local governments Federal
governments and um that's why our
country is broke thank you for your
testimony I appreciate in ourselves and
our abilities yeah thank you you bet
thank you Mr chairman um could I get the
excuse me could I get the spelling of
your last name for the record yeah sorry
if you've got a card filled out just
hand it to the clerk
okay it's it's D is and David yep e a
k my first name is is Mary Rose that's
two words got it thank you and I used to
work for the Public Health Labs as a lab
scientist three okay thank you very much
I I I encourage you to stay engaged and
involved thank you for your
testimony okay um so where were we we're
we're talking about 519 and the
plan um do we do do we need a formal
motion to have division 3 retain 519 to
make a recommendation to the full
finance committee do we need a motion
for that yes you do typically that's yes
okay I I would entertain a motion to um
recommend to the full finance committee
that we retain 519 with the idea that
the subject will be uh lifted and put
consideration uh representative priest
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I
would like to make a motion to retain
519 and S it to the um finance committee
to have a discussion
to further on to fund this bill okay is
there a
second seconded by um record
representative
seaworth okay so on this uh um I'll take
a show of hands all all those in favor
of the motion please raise your hand
discuss oh go ahead yes yes sir
discussion absolutely so I want to make
sure that I understand what the motion
was because what came out of
Representative priest was different than
what you said and I I have no problem
retaining the bill but uh at this point
in time I'm not I'm not ready to commit
it to House Bill two I'm ready to
okay it's
a horse and cart time and I'm trying to
get the two in my head uh I think before
we vote to recommend retaining we should
agree on what our intended disposition
of the material
is uh do you do you do you want to speak
further to your point about um fine with
the motion the way that representative
priest made
it you were a little more Concrete in
put putting it in House Bill
too right I I don't know if we're ready
for representative priest's motion would
you consider withdrawing it yes I'll
withdraw it all right um okay so now the
sequence I want to make sure that we've
had the discussion about taking the
material and putting it into
hb2 I I have not thought that the to be
uh controversial but I I think you have
a a point of view we need to understand
thank you uh I read through the annual
report and I mean one one thing I I
pulled out of there that was that you
know the organization is against against
the uh uh parents Bill of
Rights
uh I think that some of the services
that they're providing are are fine but
uh I'm I'm somewhat concerned about some
of the
culture that that I read in the annual
report as well so based on that uh I
feel that I'm I'm not ready to say that
to would you would you like to be able
to ask questions again of Waypoint I
think we have a representative here that
we could invite to the to talk to us are
you willing to speak to some of the the
issues represented Daniels have has
brought
up and we'll need you to state your name
and
info good morning committee my name is
Bianca jentile for the record I'm the
policy advocate for Waypoint and I'm
here happy to answer any
questions okay yes thank you um in the
annual report it indicated that two
staff members went to a and it's it's
like a five-word long uh diver came
across as a
diversity um reflection consultation
thing and uh I'd like to know a little
bit more about what that is about
absolutely so are you referencing kind
of the Dei initiatives that used to be
in place at wayp Point yes um so
obviously with the current with
legislation that is coming down from the
federal level and legislation that's on
the state level we have to comply with
legislation so those are things that we
time okay and
else I have a followup to your question
representative Daniels and that is um I
I think your testimony was is that um to
the extent that your uh Waypoint is
complying with things like the Dei
initiatives uh you're doing it in
compliance with um federal law at the at
the so it's a compliance issue and and
uh what what do you think the intent of
Waypoint is should the federal
government uh revoke its uh obligation
and removes the compliance issue from
you to um participate in in De training
well our priority first and foremost is
for the uh safety of Youth and children
and so anything that we can do to keep
the people and the population that we
serve safe that is going to take
precedence over anything and so whether
that is you know by uh
prioritizing um support by prioritizing
to vulnerable populations that's what
we're doing so whether it is in line
with Dei or not that is not the priority
the priority is to help the vulnerable
populations that we
serve okay but as part of your
compliance check off the Dei component
would be removed I I I don't I don't
know how you manage compliance but I I
imagine there's sort of a compliance
checklist of all the things you have to
do just to maintain your rating and
everything uh is that is that something
you currently track and is that
something you would continue to track if
the government the feds revoked the
requirement well we would be compliant
with what is coming from the federal
government but if they remove the
compliance issue we would also be
compliant with what is coming from the
federal government now what we would do
as an organization if both of those that
all of that compliant was was taken back
that is something that I would have to
go to the CEO to ask so I can ask that
question and definitely get back to the
committee on that thank you do you have
another question yes can you explain the
organization's opposition to the par
parents Bill of Rights I think we
consistently as an organization have
been relatively bipartisan in the sense
that we want to make sure that children
also have rights and also have the
ability to speak out especially under
circumstances where they might not have
a particular where they might not feel
safe so generally speaking anything that
we will speak out against will come from
question I understand your advocation
for the for the children but if I recall
correctly in reading the annual report
it it talked in a negative way against
the parents Bill of Rights would it be
uh amendable to you for me I from the
report I don't know exactly what you're
referencing could I go back to that and
then get back to you on that that would
be fine that' be okay representative
torki I was just going to clarify that
Bill of Rights is not state law parental
Bill of Rights is not law so if the
organization took a stand on a piece of
legislation that did not actually get
signed into law I don't
know why that's something we need to dig
into
but I'm I I I think there's so much
experience at this table I'm just going
to share my reaction to to this issue
and and invite people to offer a
different view or to correct me but um
but I would think that in sort of the uh
funding of our programs uh we need to
pay attention to whether or not we can
get the services at the right value and
the right quality and so we're we need
to take a look at all these things from
a a service capability and that any um
advocacy that they do on bills uh it is
basically First Amendment cover
and they are free to take a position on
a bill as they as they see fit within
and and and and then I I would be I
would be
uncomfortable uh uh withholding um money
over an
entity's uh
activism or advocacy that that's me does
does anyone see it differently um
representative I justess uh have some of
the same issues that representative
Daniels had and maybe to build on that I
would in order to move this forward I
would think that I'd like the
opportunity with a passage of some time
for you know to the uh rather than doing
a recommendation uh to the committee
that we allow ourselves the time to
discuss it more at the full committee
level that I mean that would be my
suggestion because I still some of the
some of the things that are happening
are happening with enough speed that
that'll allow us some time to clarify
where things where things uh stand so
that would be my view I think allowing
oursel additional time to look at this
in view of if I could comment on the
time element sure um I think we have to
make investments because time is one of
our scarcest resources at this point we
have uh the budget that's been delivered
to us we have uh billions literally
billions of dollars that we have to
decide on in a very short amount of time
and I I I just assume not recycle issues
if we can just figure out where to place
it and and move on that that would be my
preference well I wouldn't consider it
recycling I would consider it you know
prudent additional consideration I well
that's more that's more representa
seaworth uh thank you Mr chairman is a
question for you I'm new to this
process uh it would be my understanding
the purpose of putting this bill or any
other large appro Appropriations bill
into
hb2 is not to say let let's just fund it
it's to have the discussion again in the
context of the entire budget so in
seconding the motion I wasn't saying
let's let's make it
hb2 and and that's it it's to continue
that
discussion and and make the right
decisions when it comes time to actually
vote on the entirety of hb2 so so for a
new member of the committee I think you
just said it exactly right yeah the
representative priest did
you yes um again um when we heard
testimony from the attorney from
DHHS any person that enters into a
contract with them signs an agreement
that they abide by all federal and state
statutes and they sign that so I think
way um Waypoint would also do the same
so I think uh the concerns that
representative Daniels and others have
had uh does not exist because I think
they would be in compliance with it and
work toward that
so I think the implication of what you
just said is should we pass a parental
Bill of Rights then based on the
standard terms and conditions that
Waypoint would sign they would then be
obligated to respect the patient bill or
or the parent Bill rights I hope I said
parent Bill rights but correct okay so
so what what how would you like to
resolve this representative I just want
one more question is the money that
you're you're seeking the only part of
money that would be coming from the from
the state
government that does not include other
services such as Medicaid Medicare that
we would provide those Services yes this
is this is separate so representative
Edwards had asked for different line
budget line items from us and that is
something that we're putting together
and will be able to provide for the
committee thank you I I think I referred
to them as lines of business or line
yeah so however you do your internal
accounting and um it'd be great
absolutely so so do you do you want to
have us proceed with I I mean maybe we
could entertain a motion just to take
the material of 519 and place it in hb2
for further discussion and review of uh
budget allocation I'm fine with that do
I would move that we take the content of
519 and place it in House Bill 2 for
further
second you you second do you have a
question or is that a second it's a
question okay that okay um you didn't in
your motion you didn't use the word
retain we're not there yet I I I'm
explicitly splitting these steps up so
that we know where 519 there'll be
another motion just because I think
think technically that's probably the
what we need to do okay thank
you so is there a second
to I'll second the motion to move this
on okay so we'll we'll do this on a show
of hands if you're in favor of taking
the language or recommending to finance
I guess is what how we have to fa phrase
this recommending to finance that we
take the material of 519 and place it in
hb9 uh hb2 for further discussion
uh raise your
hand okay I don't see any opposed so so
now I need a second motion to recommend
to finance that we will retain HP
519 uh represent tki is there a second
go ahead tki rep representative seaworth
okay again with the show of hands if
you're in favor of retaining
recommending retaining raise your hand
thank you very much so that's that okay
so is there anyone here to introduce uh
hp71 I'm I'm not seeing anyone in the in
the
audience
um so um representative
Stringham are you able to just introduce
the bill you don't have to say anything
about it but I I think we we're supposed
to have it formally introduced to the
committee you will you you could do it
from there just if I could since this is
a work session and there's already been
a public Hearing in the policy committee
prior to this you don't actually need an
introduction if you don't want one all
right no we don't need
one okay so
um so because uh we haven't really began
to talk about hp71 at all uh as a as a
as a division um this is I'm going a
little out of order because we know more
amount about my proposed amendment than
we do the bill at this point so so if uh
so I'm going to opt for us to talk about
the amendment to
71 and um do does everyone have a copy
of
that okay so this is the non- gerine
amendment that we talked about in full
Finance the other day but it's been
revised given the um input that was
received there from Dartmouth the
hospital Association members of the full
finance committee and others to where uh
this is um is a repositioning of the of
the non-gain amendment in a way that uh
should should satisfy the concerns I
think I
heard uh what it does is it it just
takes in the terms and conditions that
the um uh Department uses to contract
with vendors uh there's already a
section and there section
61 um uh that that that requires
compliance with all the civil rights
laws and and so so what I think they
would do with lines 10 through 12 is to
insert into those standard terms and
conditions um the requirement to also
comply with the patient Bill of Rights
by citing the RSA
number so so it's it's it's not a big
deal it's just another comma and asking
them to comply with the part of our law
that is also intended to enhance our
civil rights position positions that's
let let me finish with the whole thing
okay um and
then uh you'll see on line 13 and 14 a a
repeal of what we just put
in uh with an effective date of November
2026 now now why am i setting this up on
kind of a 2-year life cycle and then it
gets removed from law it's because in
you know in my bureaucratic experience
you you don't want to Orphan legal
requirements uh in pity you you know at
some point this will become part of the
culture part of what we do and it'll
just happen naturally without requiring
a law any longer and then so as a result
let's just withdraw the law after it
becomes a clear part of the culture and
is already embedded in the in the terms
and conditions I don't imagine anyone
would remove it from the terms and
conditions when this sun sets it's just
that it's one less check mark that some
bureaucrat has to keep track of for
compliance so that that's why there's a
repeal in there and then so um so that's
really what this non gerain Amendment
does with its
adjustment um so so I would I would move
that we we we go ahead and pass h B7 uh
this amendment to hp71 20
25-
Hotel uh to supplement hp71 and we're
still going to talk about hp71 we may
not want to do any of hp71 but that will
at least be the shell for this amendment
that's my motion is is there a
second yeah um Can is there any can we
have some discussion on the on the
resulting Amendment here I yes I think I
think that comes after um oh so you just
want a motion to consider it not to
accept it okay right and and then we'll
open it for discussion is there is there
a
second uh
seconded okay so now we can get into the
discussion is there anyone in the
audience Mr hod do do you do you care to
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Matthew Hood government relations at
Dartmouth Health um with respect to the
amendment that you're proposing to amend
the HHS contracts to include a line that
requires compliance with the patient
Bill of Rights I'm we're totally
supportive of that uh fine with that
addition I can't speak to anything about
the underlying bill yeah just wanted to
be really clear about that no need no
need so so are there any questions for
Dartmouth uh I think I see two red
lights I see one red
light I see two red lights so
representative priest oh I don't have
any questions for the gentleman here
that's where we're at we're questioning
okay um thank you appreciate it I
appreciate you pulling me aside and and
talking to me last Friday so thank you
for that conversation Mr chair you got
we ended up yeah um Mr Williams do you
want to tell us something
about now now you're here representing
Melissa Saint Seer who spends her part
of her life dealing with the terms and
conditions and contracts and you're not
the subject matter expert I don't think
are
you um for the record John Williams the
legislative director for the department
and even though I've had experience in
Contracting in my prior um work within
the agency I not here in the capacity um
to discuss contracts but I am here uh um
chairman Edwards to acknowledge that in
the same way that darmouth Hitchcock is
fine with the amendment the department
is also fine with this
amendment um are there any questions for
the
Department I'm not seeing any okay thank
you Mr Williams appreciate it okay so is
there any uh further discussion about
the
[Music]
amendment M Mr Ripple you you you you
you tried to tackle me earlier what what
did I miss I just wanted to point out
from a process perspective I don't want
to speak for the house clerk but I think
because this amendment is although it's
similar to the previous Amendment
because it's being attached to a
different bill it would require another
non- gerain public Hearing in the P
finance committee before it could be
I think that's what is the probability
of you being right I I think in this
High all right can ask a question yes Mr
Ripple I know that we've been known to
do some quick physical posting of
hearings is there any way we can squeeze
it in for Tuesday when the full finance
committee meets I will check and see if
we can do
that okay let's do that if we can I this
I'm just we're just spending more time
on this than I had hoped but but it's
getting better hi do do do you have a
comment from the uh
Community yeah please and then restate
Bill hello my name's Mary Rose De and um
I support the amendment uh regarding the
patient Bill of Rights to be added um I
also um have had experience with this uh
hope and
prayer um apparently it's some kind of
law that is uh has religious
discrimination
overtones where they force somebody to
be
um I guess in in um
well like a involuntarily committed in
hopes that they find God or something
like that and the the bill itself is may
may I ask you to keep your remarks
specifically to the amendment before
well I I think it's a good idea to have
a patient's Bill of Rights um
stated clearly in in the um Bill okay
well thank you you're
welcome all right so I'll change my
motion I I I I don't even know that we
need a motion on this but um but in case
we do I I just think that uh the motion
is that we're going to take this
amendment as is to the full finance
committee to have another hearing on
this as a non- gerine Amendment with the
idea that uh we'll attach it to hp71 and
whatever form hp71 is by the time it
leaves full Finance
it's a long motion anyone car a second
that was that was the restatement am I
seconding you or making that motion
myself you're seconding great I second
okay all right so uh do you have more
discussion representative priest yes I
just want to commend you um for this
amendment I think it really clarifies it
and um and brings in the realities of
what D HHS is doing with their cont
contacting well thank you I think it's a
testimony to the genius of the process
you know I I just happen to be bumbling
along at the time and got got guided
properly so so thank you representative
Stringham yeah I would like to thank you
as well for the um uh uh movement of of
this amendment but I I want kind of have
a kind of a little bit of a comment
about uh the discussion we had because
um um you know I I think I'm suffering a
little bit from postco stress disorder
instead of PTSD
pcsd um and um you know so when that
discussion happens you know we were
talking about a specific uh case at uh
at Dartmouth Hitchcock which is not only
a great hospital for New Hampshire but
it's a great hospital for the country
and I have a high level of trust in the
medical professionals there I think um I
I I think when they come in and they
know they're getting measured on the
outcomes that they deliver for patients
that uh do things like uh get a
transplant other major procedures
they're required to establish protocols
for best
outcomes and uh you so they're measured
on these success rates and to the point
where the amount they get paid is based
on their quality scores and things
things like uh uh how many of these
patients have failures so um um you know
if if they've come up as part of the
protocol they require a series of
diagnostic tests or weight loss or o
other other things that may uh delay or
um when a patient would get a particular
treatment
um you know I trust that they've done it
from the standpoint of trying to look
out for the entire Health Care system as
well as the wealth for the patient
and um and you know I mentioned this P
pcsd or postco so when I see an
incredibly strong
reaction uh to to to me it seemed seemed
um uh substantial to an issue of
requiring masks or public health
officials being
criticized or or vaccines being a good
idea for a particular group you know I I
react probably a little more strongly
than I should and I do think that you
know use using the phrase this was an
egregious violation of the patient Bill
of Rights that's kind of what got me
started feeling a little more anxious
about this discussion and and that
Amendment so okay um thank you for the
reminder um uh it was my intent coming
into this to publicly restate my
overstatement of what happened at
Dartmouth I had an opportunity to get
additional information I I I don't think
that what happened to this particular
patient was uh intended to be systemic I
think it was a one-off that as it got
escalated through their chain of command
their leadership got involved pretty
quickly tried to understand it and
resolve it and uh and and and so uh uh I
I I I spoke more strongly than I ought
to have given that I didn't have a 360
degree view of everyone's perspective
but but since I've become U more
informed I I realize in hindsight that
my use of the word egregious was
excessive and so I would just simply say
this was a an oops that that they they
they intended to respect the Bill of
Rights
and uh it didn't happen there was a real
instance where it didn't happen um but
uh that it wasn't intentional or
systemic it just was the way it happens
in the real world where everything's
complex um ju and also to I think the
other implied point that you have is
that um in the terms and
conditions uh on the vaccine status it
it it clearly says in there that um uh
healthc care can't be uh limited solely
based on vaccine status and so vaccine
status would I think to your other point
about weight loss and other things would
be a variable in an overall holistic
view of whether or not the patient would
likely benefit from the procedures so so
I don't think and given that Dartmouth
is okay with this I I I think this
leaves them with the professional
discretion that they're entitled
to well thank you thank you very much
for that clarification and those
comments and it's consistent with uh
every other circumstances that I've
dealt with you over the last six years
that um that you're you're very
thoughtful and and moving forward I know
we're all we're all very grateful that
uh the patient uh that was concerned
about access to care
uh uh which was being uh potentially
offered him just before Christmas has
now been fully resolved and six weeks
later which um uh while I'm sure feels
like a long time that's pretty pretty
responsive for the Health Care system
that we have uh so um and once once
again I thank you for uh I I think we
all want to see uh the patients Bill of
Rights uh uh being effectively
implemented and and and I think the way
that you've written in to be included in
contracts is something I can certainly
support well thank you and and Mr hodal
a shout out to you uh if you would just
uh take back to your
leadership uh my my public apology uh
it's uh sincere I got uh I I I got a
little emotionally invested in patient
care which is where I grew up so uh Mr
chair thank you as you and I discussed
didn't feel that uh that was necessary
but I will say that the the tenor and
the thoughtfulness of this conversation
is um something that I'm glad to be here
in person to have been part of and
witness thank you all right thank you
okay so where were we we're in the
discussion I think of a very long motion
do you have more to say representative
furki we I'm I'm I'm just trying to
forgot I made a motion yeah I I think
what I think what we're doing is we're
just trying to go ahead and take this
non gerain Amendment uh and since we're
attaching it to 71 instead of 519 we
have to go to full Finance to say this
is under the other Bill yes so I know in
past meetings that we've had sometimes
we will have sort of a
non-binding vote let's say you have used
the word straw pole um maybe we could
just so we can keep a record of our
discussions a um I'd say make a motion
for a straw poll that we will be
amending House Bill 71 with your
Amendment um just so we're all clear on
where we got to this place I don't even
know if that's a legit question to ask
anything that moves us forward at this
point I I have you got an opinion Mr
Ripple on whether or not we can add this
to the calendar and have the non gerain
hearing on what next Finance meeting I
haven't heard back yet um but I I
believe House Bill 71 isn't even on the
calendar for Tuesday's meeting now non
main Amendment or not um so yeah I've
checked with the clerk I'll let you know
what I find out okay so to your straw
pole can we straw pull it to say that we
want to do the proper house procedure
and we want to keep moving this non
gerain Amendment with the intent of
attaching it to 71 whatever 71 looks
like in the
future all right all in favor of
that all right thank
um so now I think um we're on hp71 FN
and uh I don't see uh any of the
representatives that sponsored this bill
uh
present um so I uh I I I I kind of
always look forward to hearing what the
people who heard this in the policy
committee U heard on this um I think as
I've picked up uh more Grapevine than
officially is that uh the I the idea of
the
proponents was that this bill would uh
protect the facilities of our
educational system so that they can uh
in the future be uh dedicated to their
core function of educating students and
I think uh the opponents uh were
concerned that uh with this in place it
could jeopardize funding from the
federal government if we aren't uh
complying with I guess shelter
requirements for uh refugees and other
authorized immigrants so I I think
that's the setup for the pro and con um
and um so we can begin discussion on it
uh I I I the the the motion that brought
or the what happened is it passed on a
Partyline vote out of the committee it
got to the floor I think that was
essentially a Partyline vote uh here I I
don't know where we stand on it but uh
I'd like to take a motion to
OTP otpa maybe um hp71 and then we would
have a discussion on that
I'd like to have a work session which is
what this is supposed to be and um
discuss the bill itself there's no one
here but go Mr Williams is anyone from
the Department that could discuss no
well we have education here were you
71 well but sorry thank you my concern
is the fiscal note and um I'm assuming
that the potential loss of federal
revenue is to a department in DHHS which
is what I wanted some discussion on I
mean 12 to18 million is a lot of
money well okay so we get a little
you're right and we have conflicting
stuff the grid says zeros and the words
say worst case and so um you
know I I think there's a judgment in in
um I sorry no the fact that this was
this was is posted as a work session I
thought that we would have discussion on
the bill am I misunderstanding we we we
can but nobody showed up to discuss it
that's are you are you prepared to like
tell us what you think from a
Department's perspective Mr Williams if
please okay chairman Edwards and
represent toori thank you very much for
the question my apologies I was here
today prepared to discuss the amendment
that you had already acted on uh with
this committee I wasn't here prepared to
talk on hp71 I did however try to pull
up the bill on the website and
regrettably the general court website is
down so unless Mr Ripple has some
additional information that he could
provide to the committee uh otherwise I
could certainly follow up with questions
do would you state your name for the
record yes good morning my name is Diana
Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education and right now
I'm just offering technical assistance
to uh John Williams to because I was
able to get the bill online oh and I
think he's just reviewing the fiscal
note and the fiscal impact that you had
so in the absence of a question you
don't really have anything to add
regarding this
bill you didn't intend to add anything
like all good lawyers I'll I'll say it
it depends yeah um but no the Department
of Education is here obviously to offer
any technical assistance but when we
look at this bill um as previously noted
the fiscal impact they reached out to
both agencies
um Department of Education Department of
Health and Human Services the department
of education's position was that it
would not have any fiscal impact on our
agency or the local entities um DHHS did
have a fiscal impact I believe that is
what the representative was referencing
in her previous comment so I think I
have bought uh attorney Williams enough
time at this point so I'm going to
graciously hand it over so Mr Williams a
specific question do uh as this fiscal
note was developed um do you know uh how
the 12 to 18 million figure uh was
determined and and what the confidence
level of that estimate or worst case
scenario is I mean what's the background
well I first off I want to thank
attorney Diana Fenton for her assistance
because obviously her computer was
working better than mine to getting the
bill up um I am involved with the
processing of all of our fiscal analysis
on legislation working along with Nathan
white and his team and now that I saw
the reference that is stated in the
fiscal note it it did refresh my
recollection uh we we spent the time uh
when I referred the bill out to the
office of Health Equity we realized this
cut across various programmatic areas
within the department including Medicaid
and other areas so we did generate uh a
request from the other program areas to
determine whether or not there would be
any of the federal funds that may be at
risk and I do have to emphasize the word
may not shall was used in the uh fiscal
analysis so we felt it was important to
bring to the attention of the
legislature through the um um
legislative budget Assistance office
that there was the potential brisk of
these these federal dollars uh any
greater level of detail I would have to
take it back uh but I do have a
recollection of how we arrived at this
sum so Mr Ripple an LBA question do do
you have any context or background on
the development of this fiscal note uh
not very much so I'm looking at what the
department sent us right now and I'll
just say upfront I think the zeros at
the top should have said indeterminable
instead um in the body of the bill I do
think the phrase worst case scenario is
appropriate because it's unknown at this
time whether there actually will be any
impact whether there would be any impact
to Federal funding if this bill were to
pass um that would would would it imply
that the best case is it would have no
Financial impact at all I think that
would be the best case yes um looking at
the Department's response to us there's
a paragraph here that references federal
funds through the office of refugee
resettlement and the Department of
Housing and Urban Development and it
reads considering prior Grant awards
from both of these entities the
potential loss of federal revenue ranges
from 12 to 18 million so that's the only
detail we have at this
point I'm sorry I I drifted could you
say that last two sentences
again uh so this response from HHS
references funds received through the
office of refugee resettlement and the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development uh which do not require
citizenship documentation uh so it says
considering prior Grant awards from both
of those entities the potential loss of
federal revenue ranges from 12 to $18
million but they didn't tie that loss
specifically to housing them somewhere
other than public schools I mean we have
to house them not in this document I
don't know what the Department's backup
is for this document right I mean I'm
just I'm just thinking Mr Williams that
if we refuse to house them then we could
be subject to losing the grant but that
we don't get demands by the federal
government on where to house them they
wouldn't say put them in your schools or
we won't pay
you I believe that's a fair assessment
representative Edwards all right than
thank you questions from the committee
committee's got questions representative
walner thank you so as I read I
was what does what does it mean
institution
facilities it says
per prohibition of use of school or
institution facilities what what what
mean um chairman Edward words I
represent walner I I would have to get
back to you with greater detail on on
your question I do see from the actual
language in the bill it does Define uh
specifically what they're referring to
section it's shelter housing definition
yeah under the shelter and housing
definition found
on line five through six and it goes all
so so the key one seems to be coming in
around line 17 because the ones the
commas are I think fairly clear right
that we're saying that uh no no
no that if a public school a chartered
public school and a public Academy if
they were to
receive I don't actually know what that
means
okay um so I think what we ought to do
um Mr Ripple is uh is this is not on the
isn't I I I I think we need to do
another division 3 work session and
invite more expert testimony that's gone
over this and and maybe I can find it on
the YouTube um cuz you know you know we
it's probably all been said and we just
haven't listened to it
yet so so let's do when when's our next
when do we think we're going to have
another division 3 uh session when the
commissioner
comes so yes you have a budget work
session on Tuesday and Wednesday of next
week um I'll see if I can add something
to one of those days actually you have
Tuesday Wednesday and Friday of next
week Friday's yet to be scheduled
okay so so whatever works best with
getting it into the calendar without
breaking things I I I don't care which
one that goes in but just let me know
and and then we'll invite uh the
sponsors if uh in in maybe the right
departments yeah representa Mooney thank
you Mr chairman Mr Ripple with regards
to this methodology and I'm glad Mr
William emphasized the word may that's
the key word here in this
paragraph um potential worst case
scenario loss 12 to 18 million just for
our reference going forward and this
will come up again and we will get a
hard copy of the governor's proposed
budget this afternoon could you give us
a precise location in the proposed
budget accounting unit and all as to
where this would be effect this would
take
effect I will ask the department to
provide that information yes that would
be extremely helpful for our next
you further
discussion okay so so we're going to
kick this can down the road and try to
get the right people in the room
okay
um so it's not a motion but that's my
intent is that we're going to go ahead
and reschedule this and invite some
people that can take our questions and
Prov more detail is there any opposition
to that I have no opposition uh I just
say I I do think we have to understand
if there's going to be a financial
impact of implementing this and uh I
concur with um doing what we need to do
if we're going to be able to vote on the
all right my my instinct on this is that
it's there is no Financial impact it's
it's it's worst case scenarios which I
don't consider very practic
uh and uh given the way this bill has
been moved so far on partisan lines I'm
not really
expecting anything different but I we'll
see we'll see all right so um I'm show a
road all right we uh that's good so
that's it I think uh if there's anything
else to add to today's session I have a
quick question uh representative tersi I
just wanted to um Mr Ripple just so we
for planning purposes since uh the house
calendar yet does not have that Friday
schedule um Mr chairman we're looking at
Tuesday Morning is full finance and then
the afternoon is division three cor
Wednesday is all day division three
and
Friday you would have Friday afternoon
at 1 p.m. when the division of Medicaid
services which I have to tell you I
won't be here that Friday I I will be
traveling to a wedding in DC and then I
am moving to uh my new home in Arizona
uh for the week to get it ready for
renters so I'm not going to be here for
about 10 days so I I just assume do this
on Tuesday if we can
because I don't think hb2 is going to be
ready and and that's the biggest block
of time on Tuesday commissioner and hp2
I don't think hp2 is going to happen um
there may be a draft of it available
there won't be a formal document
introduced by OSS at that point but um
yeah yeah but you can add this to the
Tuesday discussion for sure I think
there'll be time for that all right
let's do that yes just quick question um
I'm glad to hear you're going to have
some time are or will we be continuing
work under representative Mooney week
the vice chair great is the chair in the
absence of the chair she runs a great
meeting I'm looking forward to it she
does she doesn't have ask enough
questions
though all right um any other discussion
on 71 or any business that we've
conducted today or any business we want
to conduct in the
future Mr Ripple you want to close us
out I have nothing more to add okay all
right well with that division three is